[Music]
in know before you go news oh you better
be prepared be prepared before you pee
in your pants yeah exactly
oh that's what the story's not know this
is submitted by crazy rotation you guys
should watch those two movie and also
funny star together oh yeah oh yeah you
watch funny story I will provide the
ability but I movies [ __ ] killing it
though yeah absolutely
Asians like funny story thus far
oh wait six is really nice [ __ ]
around
I think it's like over 100 million airs
yeah I saw it and like a hundred
something mil and I'm like wow
here are five Chinese table manners you
should know before going abroad in case
you didn't know what Chinese have table
manners I don't even know it's funny cuz
you're Chinese and you're surprised
have you seen you know you the only way
I know is that's for real is like the
chopsticks in the rice like you don't
stick that
oh yeah that's Japanese - okay so if you
put it vertical it's like you put
incense to honor the dead so it's almost
like Oh like dead people or whatever and
another one I know is if he family style
usually there's the public chopsticks
and you use those to grab yep and then
so you know you don't spread your saliva
yeah and you know for Chinese do you
cross chopsticks so like if I have to
grate and I'm all like here Steve and
then he could pick it like that you
don't cross that we can't do that no no
looks like because in a burial sent
ceremony you have like your like bones
and [ __ ] ash and they put it in the
grave and impede the the the monks kind
of cross chop sticks like yeah no you
don't do that either
number one is washing utensils before
eating in Hong Kong your server might
bring you a large bowl of water or tea
before your dim sum whatever you do
don't drink it this bolo actually allows
you to rinse your chopsticks spoons and
other utensils before dining that's so
clean it's not good to know I'm glad I
know that for sure because oh
I were to drink that [ __ ] and now I've
been like oh it's very hot water I've
never seen that in Hong Kong
I'm like I don't think it is not a
couple times I said a couple of times
what do they do like use it to [ __ ]
dip their hand and then like start
[ __ ] washing their [ __ ] utensils
well it so it sounds like very classy
right but then the way that it really
happens is like a guy that's like
[ __ ] pissed at his job and he just
throws it on the table doesn't really
explain and I've seen my dad like take
his spoons and like kind of rinse it
there and then like so from my American
perspective I'm like you're telling me
that these spoons are [ __ ] dirty
right now you're your own but for them
it's like they're already clean but make
it more clean but just the whole
experience doesn't feel classified can I
just say I get it because when I go to
places have the time I'm like I don't
know if this is [ __ ] clean and it was
just sitting on the table when I got
they could have just literally rinse it
off in us right so I'm like I want to
trust my verify please wash it in front
of my eyes man
well they're saying here that it's a
custom it's not that they're not washed
in the kitchen it's just that it's a
custom passed down through generations
and as you said that I remember it I did
see that too oh you saw it in Hong Kong
yeah a lot of Cantonese places here
they'll come out with that like hot
towel too so come up late with my hot
towel or if you take my face but if
you're like my dad then he puts it on
his face and that he goes down to China
but I was supposed to do it yeah I was
on the air China at night and I did the
whole yeah I thought you're supposed to
I just I don't know if it's a pulsar I
think like maybe Chinese people they see
themselves here but what they really do
is like if you're like scrubbing your
feet with these towels we start going in
there bad
I'll be right back he's like where are
you going I'm sorry go I'm trying to go
clean up real quick we're civilized
people shirt scrubbing away civilized
this mother all right number two is
tapping for T so when T is being poured
for you it's customary to tap lightly on
the table as a way of showing credit
it's like this oh this is like saying
thank you like this oh wow their points
it's like blackjack hit me yeah yeah
yeah that's what I would think I give
you more tea please
what if you go like this would you go
they don't know what that means over
there
[ __ ] you I mean the middle finger is
just the longest finger oh oh yeah your
Grandpa's pointing the longest one
legend has it that this custom dates
back to the teen dynasty QIS yeah ching
ching dynasty when the emperor traveled
to a tea house in disguise
and the tea house oh and then so the tea
house owner assisted the emperor in
pouring the tea for his companion or
servants in disguise and it was
customary that they would bow to the
emperor but since they were incognito
they decided to tap their fingers as if
to bow with their hand that's when that
started hmm
number three lay chopsticks flat down so
it's like what you were saying when
you're eating when you're not eating
make sure to lay your chopsticks flat
down do not leave them upright or poked
into the food because it's believed that
upright chopsticks resemble too closely
to incense that are left for the
deceased and it's also taboo to cross
your chopsticks is an X because that's a
symbol of death oh oh so it's the China
- I've known that one do they do they uh
do they bury like but like it like
American style like in China or do they
all creamy in Taiwan they only cremate
because they're not room in China I'm
not too sure but there are cemeteries
from before before they passed the law
yeah cuz yeah that's that's probably why
they do the same thing in Japan because
everything is there all cremated and
then they put it like have you guys ever
accidentally done those things well in
China do they say anything to you not in
China
yeah most cases you get a foreigner pass
but what if you're from there and like
you just slip up my mom slapped me
across the head when I did it oh wow
okay so I was like really implement but
it's also depends on intention like you
know you know like I don't know I feel
like a lot of cases now that there's so
many travelers like they don't
automatically expect that you're Chinese
or Japanese or whether that's true yeah
but then it is kind of weird though to
just stick it in your rice like that
right and then walk away you know Casey
was the one that told me yeah you should
never do that because whatever whatever
he taught me that but he's always
sticking his chopsticks in the rice oh
my Casey what are you doing I think he
was doing that so that you can make a
good impression on his parents and that
you don't look crazy
I don't care oh no his prints don't care
either but like for him he's just like
I'm not superstitious I don't care I'm
like see you made me superstitious and
they're gonna because not even
superstitious it's just etiquette he
said it was superstition that's how you
that's how he's like this is a
superstition because it sounds like a
superstition inviting the dead to your
yeah what I was taught is that it
reminds people of the funeral so you're
doing things that symbolizes death or
the bathroom and it's like all these
things that the etiquette comes from oh
I don't want it to like feel like I'm
[ __ ] in the bathroom or or I'm in the
funeral or I'm in this or whatever
yeah number four
chain-of-command oh yeah you know it
well I don't know for at least for my
family if all the table is set the
hierarchy of people that I get to touch
the food first go from the eldest to the
youngest so you could if the if the
food's there and grandpa wants to be mr.
talkie we're all just staring at oh wow
like an hour and this little is just
[ __ ] talking his [ __ ] gums away I'm
like until he says eat that's how it is
in my family I'm getting there's a
hierarchy oh don't even I'm getting tiny
thing
I'm sure it is but when grandpa unlocks
it then now now the adults can unlock it
and after they unlock it then the kids
can I feel like that's pretty that's so
interesting
that's pretty like common among like
even non-asians but I think the one
that's very Asian is the pouring of the
tea or pouring of the drink so then you
know you're supposed to pour an order of
rank
so who's the matriarch or patriarch for
the famines pouring those at the
youngest for Japanese or it's supposed
to be but not children like they're not
expected to do it like they're just
dumbass kids you know but then like
maybe the wife or or someone that's kind
of like second or third in command so
then they'll pour it or like this the
son which is the patriarch of the family
open the grandpa is gonna be it's the
the Sun pours for the grandpa I mean
enough the dad pours for the grandpa
okay you know and in the son might pour
for the dad and then it's just like an
order yeah
oh man serve men serve men yeah yeah
many Smiths what mean like if there's a
mom typically the mom would be like the
one that does everything right but then
like if you're a rich family then of
course you have like servants or
whatever but if it's in this system then
yeah because I know like in Korean
family um it's that but then the one
that serving is like the the wife to the
youngest son like she's the one that's
responsible the wife to the youngest I'm
her son
no so the sons um the youngest son his
wife Oh
so if Kerry Kerry got married yeah that
was why he's now like taking care of
everyone she's the PA oh yeah yeah she
does the dad than the mom then Casey
then you then then it's them my mom used
to get pissed off [ __ ] off because we
would anytime we're at my grandma's
house the women they call my anthro
expected to serve all my uncles and like
my grandma was expected to serve my
grandpa and so my mom was expected to
serve her brothers and she was like I am
NOT serving my brothers they can get out
their [ __ ] asses
serve themselves every single time it
was angry family so Jill I I don't know
I I had I had to be the chill one that
wasn't always my thing probably freaking
out man these guys are crazy I don't
wanna be like them yeah he's chill he's
really all right last one on this list
is fighting for the check oh my god
Mexicans do that too dude this is I'm
sorry this is again I have to say this I
that was what I was taught
fight for the check you the big the
biggest man in the room pays the bill
yeah I seen this in a lot of traditional
families not just Asian I fight my
Nikki's dad all the time
I fight my family all the time yeah you
have to even if you're not gonna pay you
still have to fight the level of the
fight though it's kind of embarrassing
and funny the way that you see them
going for it it's too much fighting like
their friendly fighting like none and
like they're moving the table and the
drinks we go to the cash register and it
looks like they're boxing each other
about I do like it's an NBA basketball
game trying to have a rebound and [ __ ]
they like sticking their [ __ ] legs in
front of each other like I go to the
bathroom and then I pay the bill and
then they just bring the receipt later
and that's supposed to be busy it's like
really dope really nice worth it every
time
[Music]
[Music]